hi i'm ria i'm a tasty producer and
welcome back to make it fancy today i've
been challenged to take a common food
and
make it fancy let's take a look at the
rolls you must completely use the food
given you can only add to the food you
can buy whatever ingredients you wish
once you begin cooking you must complete
upgraded dish in 30 minutes let's see
what it is this time
it's a twinkie i actually never had a
twinkie before i feel like i have a lot
of things i've never tried before this
show the first time i saw twinkie was
when i watched this zombie movie called
zombieland
it's very oily it has a nice golden
brown icy cream inside
it's not bad
it looks very good and i don't like
myself liking that it's sweet you have
to put something to cut the sweetness
cream it soft then cake it soft so i
want something crunchy in there i got
some good ideas and i'm excited to make
it
[Laughter]
make it fancy right here's what i got
bitter sweet chocolate white chocolate
pistachio sprinkles dried cranberries
freeze dry raspberries and cocoa nibs
and from the pantry i got brandy and sea
salt one more thing
i got more twinkies let's get started
make it fancy
let's set the timer for 30 minutes and
30 minutes starts now
so first i'm going to start roasting
pistachio i just want it to give a nice
toasty flavor and what i'm doing i'm
going to chop some cranberries
the people who just start watching from
this episode i call my knife my ladies
and spa means sharpening knife coats you
know it's a nice spa treatment for my
lady knives my ladies are in spa right
now put it in a bowl if you are roasting
nuts on a stovetop just keep moving the
pan so it doesn't get burned just
checking timer it's 28 minutes right now
i'm going to open twinkies
my favorite treats while don't be
apocalypse i hope zombie apocalypse will
happen in the future but if it does i at
least know how to make twinkie fancy
once you start smelling like nice toasty
nut smell and it's nice and crunchy it's
ready so you want to
put in a pan and just like set aside i
chose cocoa nibs because it's bitter and
the twinkie is super sweet so i want to
balance it out and also kakaone is very
crunchy so i think it kind of gives a
nice crunch what does it feel like it's
nice
[Laughter]
so i'm adding brandy because i like
dessert with a little bit booze in it in
japanese we say otonangaoji which
translates to adult flavor so i don't
want to mush too much it's still fluffy
it's a good point because i'm going to
shape it let's check the timer 21
minutes left
it tastes great
i think brandy helped and i feel like it
needs a little bit more cocoa leaves and
cranberries i think nobody can tell this
is twinkie secret weapon
ice cream dishes so you can shape it
evenly round shape
this is done we have
1744
now i'm going to use white chocolate and
bittersweet chocolate and melt them in
the microwave
chocolate is nice and melty i'm going to
use this stick so i'm dipping chocolate
into this cake bowl so when you are
dipping chocolate it doesn't fall off
it's kind of become a stopper so i'm
doing some with white chocolate and some
with dark chocolate i have this baby one
i'm gonna just use this for tasting
so i'm surprised twinkies it's holding
this shape nicely i'm happy
so far so let's check the timer 12
minutes all right now i'm going to put
them in the freezer until i prepare for
my decoration while it's freezing i'm
going to grind pistachios in the
processor
i don't want to make it too powdery i
want to make a little bit like
pebbles
i have a freeze dry raspberry i'm going
to just crush them until like a pebble
same as pistachio it's fun i have about
eight minutes twinkie cake bowls are
out from freezer it's not completely
frozen it's nice and cold the first one
is going in dark chocolate i'm using
spoon so the bottom part also covered
with chocolate it's runny so i just
wanted to make sure completely covered
and this goes into sprinkle
cute i only have four minutes left i'm
gonna move on to white chocolate white
chocolate one i'm coating as thin as
possible so it doesn't overpower the
flavor because white chocolate is a
little bit sweeter
cute like i said anything around it's so
cute so i have 30 seconds left i'm going
to make baby one for myself
[Music]
i like sea salt
and i'm done
[Music]
welcome ryan for twinkie 1
twinkiewonderland
awesome
does this resemble a twinkie
is your question this does not resemble
a twinkie growing up i didn't really
have many twinkies i think my first
encounter was like during some sort of
school lunch trade or something like
that some white child gave me their
twinkie you gave some asian and i gave
them some asian food chips
this is delicious
a little bit of hip action yeah okay
i'm gonna have
this one because it kind of looks like
hot cheetos do i yeah
oh my god
okay good
you made it fancy it tastes so
good make it fancy
the first to make it fancy i choked on
the first bite and they cut it out of
the episode
do you wanna water i don't have water i
have a little bit more than i left if
you will do you like twinkie do you grow
not eating i like a twinkie my parents
never got me like snacks so i would
always be like that kid staring at your
snack at recess you know where i'm from
the cool kids got the twinkies
[Music]
do you want to put on the plate
i like the pistachio with the twinkies
rien made this twinkie fancy
make it fancy
thank you for watching if you make it
please tag me on the instagram if you
want me to make something fancy comment
below and don't forget to dance
make it fancy
[Music]
you